these pictures were being broadcast live
on TV the car in front had been stolen
with a child inside the driver
carjacking a second vehicle
and speeding off the wrong way on a busy
freeway with police in pursuit in
Colorado rush hour you reach speeds of
up to 100 miles an hour even in a
country well used to watching real-life
car chases this was extraordinary one
officer was injured during the chase but
even when the suspect collided with
another car there was no stopping him
dragging the driver away and getting
behind the wheel I literally listening
on the radio about this car chase
happening and thinking on blood i'm not
on i-25 could sound like that's where it
was and as I was going through the
intersection here at Peoria at the
corner of my eye I see a car coming at
me that has run the red light pretty
fast speed he t-boned me on the
passenger side I start like flying into
the intersection basically two other
cars hit me and then I hit a guy that
was in the turn lane the chase then
continued until another collision and
the driver setting off on foot he was
arrested as he tried to scale a fence 29
year old ryan stone now in custody for
theft and carjacking it had lasted an
hour and covered 75 miles greg milam Sky
News Los Angeles